all right so we're back it's on a Monday
and Sprite not was probably won't be a
very long one I don't really have a
whole lot in a really long one yesterday
we just went off on all kind of crazy
yeah what what she starts getting me
talking telling stories [ __ ] about the
scorpions
I meant to like look up some of those
other stories that happen around that
time period but I forgot to do it man
there's a lot of stories stories about
rumors that had rumors that formed
around me oh yeah I don't want to talk
about that why not talk about well yeah
I mean you don't have to like go into
like super elaborate detail or anything
yeah when Jenny met me all right
there were guys that were gunning for
and they were saying don't mess with
that dude don't mess of that dude he's
bad yeah it's true you are you're
terrible yeah there was this rumor that
I would go to these clubs and just like
I'd get blown in the club but it was
true and from that all of a sudden you
know I I got a super bad reputation with
the guys but I ended up getting a good
reputation with the girls because of
what the woman said yeah yeah and that's
all I'm gonna say about that it's very
funny because you didn't because I've
you know I've lived in Central Florida
my whole life um you had just moved here
good what maybe like a year before I met
you something like that yeah like cuz
what did you move here what your house
Nate 2008 no okay so maybe that was
longer ago so maybe you lived here like
this thing's them it was like the middle
of 2008 where I moved here okay so uh
yeah so I feel like
it was probably I think it was 2010 or
2011 2010 I'm anyway yeah and um yeah
you did kind of have you did kind of
have like it not a bad reputation
necessarily but you said I was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah you did not you did which was
not really going like once I met you and
like started talking to you and so
because I was still married at that time
and I was like you were I don't know why
you got that reputation because you were
no more [ __ ] than and but considerably
less funny yeah it was fear all right
they thought I was gonna take advantage
of [ __ ] yeah and really really I wasn't
interested in taking other people's
girlfriends yeah that's what it was I
think yeah i n't care yeah you know and
you know it's friends with sonya already
by that time and some other people and i
was just minding my own business really
yeah or anything else you know but i
already cut over it they were already
blaming me for [ __ ] before that one
situation even happened yeah yeah I mean
how many these dudes are here gonna
[ __ ] tell you like oh wow
some girl wanna blow me I would say no
now are you [ __ ] crazy it wasn't like
it was out in public yeah girl I knew
just [ __ ] grab me and [ __ ] pulled
me off in the [ __ ] corner you know I
mean [ __ ] one really corner it was
like behind a curtain yeah yeah part of
the club was [ __ ] closed off had big
curtain you know it's just [ __ ] [ __ ]
like that and she's getting busy [ __ ]
worshiping worshiping me tell me when
you're done actually nah I'll tell you
but it was all good you don't I mean and
[ __ ] then she goes right around [ __ ]
it tells Tina Tina stuff you know Tina
told Tina last night yeah it was you
know she was the girl to [ __ ] help
Paul run the place as Paul's wife yeah
and
Tina was amazed so I got this lucky
killer wrap yeah yeah with the girls but
all the guys are [ __ ] hate not you
know the man but here's the weird thing
half the guys didn't believe that it
happened so you know what can i used to
think you're an [ __ ] because you know
i used to believe that you used to sit
around and [ __ ] get head and [ __ ] in
the club you know now that i know yes
that's [ __ ] no no yeah one time and
another time yeah it was not they were
like she was like having it all time and
it wasn't like you instigated it no he
was just kind of like hey come back here
and he was just like okay she was
married yeah that's right she was
married what happen to her man she left
yeah
like my problem she was true I was
shooting out there she's funny yeah but
she went out she [ __ ] bragged about
it like immediately
yeah that's pretty yeah yeah talks like
she did on purpose like just but yeah
that is it's really funny because when I
you know before I knew you that well and
yeah I did get like some guys that were
like but then like you know once I got
to know you and stuff oh my god yeah
okay whatever
that's yeah and that did not hurt my
popularity as a matter of fact it
magnified it yeah well people that knew
you knew that that was crap and then
like when people later like met you yeah
it wasn't well they knew how it happened
yeah they were doing worse that's my
it's like so you get a reputation for
doing that it's like I know some [ __ ]
that happened with some other people's
wave yeah that's like that's like not
even bad like I said it's know if no
one's you know no one's consent was
violated nobody saw anything
no they're [ __ ] dudes is [ __ ]
basically [ __ ] basically date rape
[ __ ] girls in there yeah we tried to
shut him out I mean it to be
err they have a really bad reputation
too but you know it's like considering
what that it's like what you did is like
not like I said nobody do date rape that
[ __ ] girl and then took pictures of
it mm-hmm and was sharing pictures of it
yep special yeah like he didn't think
that was date rape well she was just
unconscious yeah yeah yeah thanks that's
okay he's just who thinks that's okay
[ __ ] nut man dude was a [ __ ] nut
and he kept coming back around yeah we
couldn't get rid of him couldn't get rid
of even though everyone's everybody's
like dude man you get yeah yeah what
else [ __ ] has happened before the
show kind of sleepy kind of sleepy I ate
a big old [ __ ] bowl of spaghetti
meatballs yeah I got that carb crash so
I'm like yeah well I probably woke you
up early too well I got up the normal
time I get up I woke up at 6:30 and uh
then I was like getting ready to go out
for a walk and I think you woke up cuz
you were awake when I got back from my
walk
yeah well Pookie was what what the hell
was she doing last night was she
crawling around under the bed I don't
know I woke up at like 2:00 or 3:00 in
the morning all I heard was like
underneath the boxspring yeah what she
does is that she lays on her back puts
her hands and feet up and puts her claws
out and grabs the bottom of the bed and
drags herself it goes all the way under
yeah her back drags on the ground
yes hilarious she just really enjoys
that she doesn't have two chairs tail
yeah but [ __ ] yeah she'll get out of the
bed and do that and like sometimes too
it's like if there's a there's like a
gap between like that and the head of
the bed in the wall it's like sometimes
she'll come up there she'll try to climb
up through there and like try and jump
out like where the pillow I cants is
saying she is but in in a funny way
she's cute she's clown yeah she's not
doing anything like to be malicious
she's just having like a good time and
kid is a clown she is she needs a little
jester outfit yeah she would look too
you know yep you know what she did
yesterday morning was she was out of
treats again and so she went up on the
thing like underneath the TV yeah and
she did was a little pile of blu-rays
and she just left there went what yeah
and they went crash yeah and I was like
oh she must be out of treats again and
she was that's I know exactly what she's
doing when she makes all that [ __ ]
alright you look like you're about to
land you ready to fall asleep fall
asleep and he seems you want to go take
a nap yeah I'm gonna take an old man
that I think cookies and they're
sleeping on the bed you can go cuddle up
next cookie or fall asleep y'all can
take it old man that been a little bit I
don't want anybody to [ __ ] like be
afraid that I'm running out of material
that I [ __ ] can do this [ __ ] [ __ ]
all the time it's just right now you
catching me in a moment of weakness I'm
getting ready to write this cookbook I
got some good plans for this like yeah
we were just talking about it before we
turn the thing on
it's like well cuz I didn't realize like
how many people I came on the YouTube
comments and were like oh my god it's a
great idea well and we want to like make
it make us so foreigners can do this
[ __ ] too because we got a lot of people
like in Europe that I'm gonna I'm gonna
be talking about certain types of
cuisine they may not be able to get the
components so in the cookbook it'll be
how to make the components - yeah all
right so it's gonna be pretty good how
to make pizza crust they make the dough
from nothing like the right way all
right what kind of flour to get how to
make jelly how to make peanut butter how
to make certain kind of sandwich spreads
that way you can you could execute these
these recipes no matter where you are in
the world that's how I want to do it
yeah if you can get all the yeah yeah so
is so you're at least have an acceptable
version of what I'm talking about it's
gonna have a drink menu and everything
I'm gonna have to put some stuff in
there that my grandma used to make like
gooey butter cake you can do that yeah
all right
cocoons never cocoons yeah about
proteins yeah yeah oh yeah prolly ins we
go
yeah put southern food in there we're
gonna have some foreign food how to make
Mexican food how to make corn tortillas
and flour tortillas if you if you don't
if you can't get Mexican food let me
[ __ ] like that
it's Guinea and like I said I want to
make it like funny too because we want
like some of your commentary and [ __ ]
like yeah there so even if you're not
gonna cook the [ __ ] in it'll still be
funny like were three how to make salsa
how to make sour cream yeah you can make
eco there's a lot of stuff that you know
that that southerners and just Americans
that generally eat that a person in
Europe can't get or it's like a pain in
that Corsican yes or it's a bad version
of it yeah yeah like I've heard that
some foreign peanut butter is [ __ ]
just inedible
that an American would need that it's
either too sweet or not sweet enough for
it's the wrong texture but there's a way
to make that to make like a a real
wholesome [ __ ] good taste in peanut
butter at home you don't need you don't
need it's pretty easy to make easy innit
jelly do they make tail yeah making Joey
I like chunky yeah some brands are
better than others but it's all pretty
good yeah and I got you know and also
[ __ ] [ __ ] having to do with
hamburgers too like a Brazilian
hamburger is [ __ ] terrible compared
to an American hamburger and they call
it a merit they know it's an American
thing and they try to do it all the time
they can't get the bun right all right
but it's hard to do there shit's too
[ __ ] sweet and it's too flaky it's
like I don't know what kind of dough
they used and then the ketchup that the
ketchup they used was wrong it was my
resting yeah it was almost and it was
real sweet sugary and cheap tasting
which the the ketchups here i mean they
run the range like some of them are too
sweet for some people I know like you
know a lot of the brands have a
different like sweetness level to them
yeah but I was working at a restaurant
for a while and the guy who read it man
he was fantastic she's fantastic chef he
was younger than me this is right after
I got out of the army I worked worked
for a while and we made our own salad
dressings and our
condiments and I was involved in making
all that [ __ ] yeah we used to make our
own ketchup and it was just [ __ ]
better than any ketchup any Heinz 57
better better than hunts it better than
anything well yeah everything just have
to know what you're doing you know
what's good curry ketchup oh yeah yeah
okay I got it once I was at I was at uh
pomfrit in New York City yeah and it's
like they give you those twice you know
this twice fried like Belgian fries they
give you like a big cone of that [ __ ]
and then they have like sixty bajillion
different like condiments and curry
ketchup was like my favorite how to make
mayonnaise yeah that's another one that
we used to make mayonnaise that was just
like hard-boiled egg yolks and vinegar
and we used to pur whip it out and there
was some other stuff in there forgot
what is he and make a beautiful [ __ ]
mayonnaise which that's a French thing
really I think they have ended that but
some countries you can't get good
mayonnaise and it all makes a difference
and all that stuff well yeah I mean
every little thing it's like you know
this the stuff that we buy here like I
don't even remember what brand of like
ketchup we have in the fridge is
probably Heinz or something and we have
like Hellmann's mayonnaise probably
which is you know that's good on a
burger but like obviously they're gonna
make all your room [ __ ] it's gonna be
way better yeah yeah cuz like in South
America you just couldn't get a good
hamburger couldn't you could never get a
good hamburger in Korea it's like that
is not a [ __ ] hamburger not a burger
yeah you know it seems like it would it
seems like it would be hard to mess that
up
I know it's very but there's so many
components yeah that have to go
correctly or at least possibly they have
to go correctly for the American
expectation of where things are supposed
to taste yeah just the wrong bun is
enough to [ __ ] it up or too many fillers
inside a damn beef patty just there's a
lot of [ __ ] they can go wrong you can go
like that's [ __ ] soybean you kick
that [ __ ] out you know I mean that's not
a hamburger yeah soybeans just it just
doesn't work and like I said the ketchup
yeah I don't make a break yet yeah it's
like it doesn't seem like it would be a
big deal but it really is oh yeah the
condiments man [ __ ] serious [ __ ]
serious
you know components without it you just
you just don't have it it's just not it
um there's a lot of things that have to
go right
Brazilians also [ __ ] up Pizza all the
time the crust was never really a crust
like I like I make it was more like a
soft bread yeah and the pizza can't was
more like steamed more than it was yeah
yeah because was it more like focaccia
or no no it's shitty pizza
it was more like shitty shitty pizza
because their ovens were never could
never really get up to the [ __ ] high
temperatures that you need you can't
really cook a pizza under 500 degrees
you wanted but more like 550 525 well
well we make pizza here because we just
have like a regular electric stove you
put it up to 525 times as high as it'll
go
but leave it on for like a really long
day yeah you got to cook it on you can't
cook it on metal it's got to be cooked
on stone yes it was the stone in there
you just like leave it 25 hot hot for
like an hour - yeah yeah cooking times
only 15 minutes on a pizza yeah
and that's for a large one small ones
might be more like twelve twelve minutes
but it's just so hot in there it's like
it's supposed to be like a kiln yeah
very much like it's very much like it's
cooked by induction all the heat from
the damn stone just gets sucked into the
pizza from the bottom and that's really
where the cooking action is coming from
but so that stones got to be super hot
and the dough has to be aged and it's
got to have it'll be thin and kind of
crispy and have a nice kind of stretch
to it and there's a weird
I'll show you there's a way it's gotta
be
and once you deviate from that cooking
time and temperature you're gonna [ __ ]
pizza all up that's not pizza high
temperature low cooking time well Brazil
Brazil didn't there they're like a 350
Titan [ __ ] where everything and
they're trying to cook on metal and
they're trying to cook everything at
once
you know I mean
in a restaurant so there might be four
other things in that oven being cooked
at the same time and then the pizza just
sits out there on the counter you know
to me people order slices off of it
until it's gone and they got a [ __ ]
[ __ ] like green peas on a pizza and [ __ ]
it chick peas on a damn pizza I remember
being in the UK and seeing corn niblets
or corn yeah when you see [ __ ] like that
just throw it away I think that I think
that Asian yeah they don't know anything
about pizza every strange every country
seems to have their version of pizza but
pizza got famous not because of Italy
got famous because of [ __ ] America
and it that's where it really got famous
is in the Chicago area of Chicago New
York area and the very first versions of
pizza that came out the the oldest one
recorded with this was you know in the
early 1900s I forgot exactly maybe it
had something to do with an Olympic
event that was going up it was just a
round flat piece of bread cooked at very
high temperature low time and it was
three colors it was green white and red
like the Italian flag yeah and the red
was just Tomatoes and then it had
spinach for the green and the white was
the cheese and it was totally separate
it wasn't mixed on top of each other
that's what that's what started as not
gonna live bread with some [ __ ] on it
yeah bread with some [ __ ] on it by
Italians Italian Americans down here you
know I mean they're now living in luxury
compared to a it was back in Sicily or
whatever they've got all this food now
so they took ideas like that and they
just made what they considered to be a
richer version of it yeah put tomato
sauce on but a lot of tomato sauce put a
lot of cheese on it put a lot of meat on
it you know that and that's sometimes
they put another crust on the top and
call it pizza pie yeah so and only
Italian Americans knew about it for a
long long time it got famous because
gangsters got famous yeah all right
because they write newspaper articles
the bottom you know that you know what's
what's-his-name got the guy from Al
Capone I think that's the first time it
was Rick really mentioned in the media
that Al Capone liked to hang out at
these things called pizzerias yeah
and yeah I mean people got interested
what the [ __ ] is a pizza pie then yeah
Capone to go on about pizza and a damn
article you know and that's really what
made pizza famous so yeah cuz it got
cool yes yeah not non Italians are like
I wonder what that tastes like you know
and they're trying to make yeah but it
was evidently was for a long time it was
just [ __ ] up most of the time well
because they didn't really did not
really now to me it took Italian
Americans really yeah to teach the rest
he nine states how to make it and from
there that was kind of a global
phenomena from there it got more famous
Italy was doing stuff like that but
Italy's version of it was just kind of
like bread bread with stuff on like a
focaccia oh yeah it's more like what
their pizza with all that [ __ ] conscious
all the time so guys just good too but
evidently now you can go to Italy and
you can find things that are kind of
like italian-american versions of pizza
it's like that and I don't know like
maybe if people that aren't from the
United States don't know but I mean the
New York Pizza versus Chicago pizza
that's still like a big debate because
Chicago makes that deep-dish yeah that's
like that some people are like that's
not people's like a casserole or a
lasagna or whatever whereas New York's
is like you know thinner crust
reviewable you know and they usually
sell them by the slice so you can like
eat them on the street or whatever yeah
I do not have a dog in this fight I will
eat either kinda but they're both very
good and I don't really have a
preference over I mean I have a
preference over toppings but I'll eat
pretty much anything on a pizza except
for like weird [ __ ] like I said like
corn niblets and that kind of crap it's
like I don't want that if you don't have
a pizza stone and and the equipment to
get it off the stone which is like a big
paddle thing you know called a peel
looks like a big snow shovel if you
don't have that then that means you're
restricted to cast iron and you can cook
it in a caster yeah we've done that
before that's good - yeah so if you
don't have stone you got to have a cast
iron pan well everyone should have a cow
sorry yeah yeah if they're gonna cook
yeah you got cast iron skillet you can
get a pretty good pan pizza going yeah
um but if you just kind of try to cook
it on those little skinny pizza pans
you're [ __ ] tripping you're never
gonna get that
that that you're never gonna get that
crust right metal just can't do that
kind of metal can't do it you need to
have a [ __ ] heavy cast-iron because
you need some the heat has to conduct
properly yeah and you just I just
learned it through experience over and
over again another guys will tell you
you gotta have one of the other yeah or
you could cook it on a wire screen
that'll work too there's a lot of
pizzerias that'll do that yeah you can
they'll cook fast like that it's not
quite as good as on a cast-iron skillet
or a stone though yeah it's just I mean
you can do it you know you can do it on
a metal pan that's edible but it's just
not it's not peak pizza it tastes like
frozen pizza no matter what you do
pretty much yeah you're not gonna get
that really nice living room is crunchy
Krita kind of crust on the bottom yeah
yeah and like you said though gotta be
aged as well yeah again it'll work like
cuz you've made dough and then we made a
pizza the same day but it's always
better if you leave it a second third
day and then make a pizza it's gotta be
under control FEMA fermentation yeah
it's gotta sit there and kind of ferment
if it gets too fermented then it starts
falling apart you can't really work with
it he gets too slimy you can't make the
dough yeah make the crust with it it
tastes good though you like I've dropped
it into a cast-iron skillet yeah I like
day five and pushed it in there and put
a little bit of flour on top of it so I
could work with it and it's great it's
like a sourdough yeah you know yeah it
does come out now but it would only be
good for ona cast iron yeah because if
you try to like roll it out it's just
gonna like yeah terrible holes in it
yeah I'll get into that when we write
the [ __ ] rest yeah we need to get on
that that's another thing I need to get
you know southern desserts like cocoons
we'll talk about that bra leans like I
said I wanted to do butter cake because
my grandma in there put maybe some
seafood dishes you know maybe well [ __ ]
that's pretty easy [ __ ] like crawfish
boil I think I think you can find that
on the Internet
well you can find most things on the
internet like I said but it's you know
it's just kind of like what we cook a
lot
and how you make it yeah some of the
stuffs family recipes yeah so I think
that'll be because you know people still
put cookbooks out even though yeah you
can find a recipe for pretty much
whatever you want on the internet but
it's like you know I think if people
want a cookbook they want like part of
your like personality and it yeah and
stuff that you personally have cooked
and that you've experimented with in
that yeah but if you guys have any
suggestions if you're like in another
country and yet you have suggestions you
know like what it is you want in that
cookbook what then I can come up with
some stuff because there's a lot of
stuff that I cook or have access to that
I don't mention on the show yeah you
know and you know you might be in a
country where you know porks more common
than beef or chicken you know whatever
and you know you might want to know you
know but [ __ ] I can teach you how to
make fried chicken yeah and fried
chicken and biscuits you know with
[ __ ] coleslaw and [ __ ] like that you
know look at like you're getting KFC you
know I don't know depends what you guys
are registered in yeah I could make
anything yeah so if anybody's got
recommendations like what you want to
see in there we're gonna start making
like lists of stuff that'll be it stuff
that'll be in there and we'll have to
start like you'll have to make it all
and take pictures I will probably we
will probably have to have a section
aware how to make condiments and
dressings yeah you should do that okay
because that was something that you used
to do like where are you Sora right well
that way you know if I'm talking about
if I mention making a hamburger and it's
best with this and that you know
then it'll else in another section will
tell you how to make that stuff yeah or
a better version of maybe you know a
better version of ketchup or a better
version of mayonnaise something like
that yeah cuz you always make your own I
mean he makes his own salsa you make you
know what the [ __ ] tartar sauce
yeah dips salad dressings sometimes
depends on what I have salad dressing is
easy to make yeah sour cream and cream
that's the basis of all the creamy ones
rest of them are all some kind of
vinaigrette yeah if it's blended or not
blended it's a that can death that's a
whole book into itself though I want to
keep it kind of simple
like American comfort foods and some of
the [ __ ] we eat around here
yeah alright so we're gonna wrap it up
for this Monday we did pretty good for
not having a goddamn thing to talk about
now mixing it up you gotta go check the
mail so you gotta go check the mail and
take your old man nap and go check okey
young all the sleeping yeah this likes
to spend an animation yeah yeah alright
so you guys have a good rest of your
Monday and we'll talk to you guys again